[Music]
this is kakigori it's a traditional
japanese dessert similar to the shaved
ice desserts that you probably know but
of course here it is so much more than
that
[Music]
let's start with a quick history the
dish was originally a summer treat meant
to help cool down the wealthy elite of
japan during the late 1800s
the ice was topped with fruit syrups and
teas grown and harvested locally and in
some places it still is
this is aya eguchi in her shop in otsu
[Music]
[Music]
and to get very thin ice there is of
course a special machine for that which
you can find in tokyo at kohli ishibashi
this is kumiko ishibashi in her shop
[Music]
okay so we've got our pure non-freezer
made ice shaved by hand to perfection
based on the weather
next we need toppings
our last stop is the chasan raku tea
house in kyoto an area known for its
matcha and this is hiroki
actually
[Music]
for more traditional matcha flavors to
mainstream ones like strawberry hawaii
blue melon cream this dish has range
but the only thing that matters at the
end of the day
is how delicious it is
[Music]
you